on this day in 2016 people in britain
voted
to leave the european union an event
known forever more as brexit
well five years ago very few people were
predicting that brexit would pass
the results shocked much of europe and
the world
the brexit referendum remains one of the
most important
news events that we have covered here at
dw news
here is a look back at the evening of
june 23
2016 and a reminder of what we were
reporting the night
that brexit began it's about british
identity which is always funny
because they live on an island we really
haven't had a story like this
in in our generation have we someone is
going to be
crying this evening you think so in a
few hours time
we'll know the answer i'm brent goff and
my name is christopher springate and
this
is dw news the uk decides
we don't really know what that would
look like or or which direction
different european countries would want
to take or indeed you insist
aren't you playing down the importance
of the of the british with that though i
mean we've always talked about and
mckellar correct me if i'm wrong but
we've always talked about the the berlin
paris london you know this almost this
axis here this is
this is what the eu feeds off of and if
we lose that
if we if we lose london that's a third
of everything well it also depends on
which level you're talking about
economically britain might take a hit
but so will europe
and certainly will germany um the uk is
a vital export country that germany
exports into
um so there is something to lose
across the board so
whatever comes of this something has
been broken
this this um the spell if you like
of not questioning the european union
um being in place has been broken just
by posing this question
something has been broken wow well you
just saw him at the big table five years
ago with me he is with me again tonight
right here
john worth he is a germany based british
political commentator and blogger
he has been a part of our brexit
coverage from day one it's good to have
you back in the studio for a change
it's glad to be back perhaps what went
through
your mind john when when you looked back
when you saw that clip there and you
looked back at the coverage five years
ago
i remember being in this very studio
that night and at some point dawning on
me about three o'clock in the morning
when the results came through that
this is going really badly and actually
this could
actually really happen and we've still
then been picking through all of the
kind of consequences of that since
what i think none of us could really
have known is on that
that evening we could have expected a
bumpy ride
over the the the five years to come but
perhaps not one that's been so
politically difficult
so contorted uh has has come to pass did
you did you think that it would
take so much time to go from the actual
referendum being passed to when
brexit would finally be a reality
i think that's hard to say because we
knew on one hand that trying to deal
make a trade deal with the european
union is a time-consuming process
so at one level britain's actually
solved that comparatively quickly
what i think we couldn't really
predicted is the amount of
political breakdown that britain has had
to go through in order to manage to get
to that point
and actually no one's ever really tried
to do anything like this before so kind
of negotiating when the clock is ticking
and i think we've only understood in the
last six months actually doing that you
know
under that time pressure is a really bad
idea because the british are now only
beginning to discover actually a lot of
these problems
are a lot more difficult than they
thought they would be uh when they were
so confident that there would be
benefits of brexit
when you look at the uk and the european
union since that fateful night five
years ago
what do you think has changed the most
i think britain is still playing out
that game about brexit even now brexit
dominates everything is he
playing a role in britain's coronavirus
response um and so
britain rather than being a political
system which is between the traditional
party of the left the labour party and
the traditional party the right the
conservatives
has become essentially the conservatives
being the pro-brexit party and everyone
else wondering what to do about that
on the european union side it's a bit
more complicated it's a bit more nuanced
the european union at one level
stands actually in some things more
united than it did back then five years
ago
because all of the 27 remaining
countries have said hang on a minute we
don't actually want that so they've
looked at what
britain has had to confront and don't
want to do that themselves
and in some things again the eu's
coronavirus responds to eu's budget
the european union is perhaps better
placed today than was the case
five years ago but nevertheless losing a
big member state 65 million people the
economic consequences
of course that's going to be a major hit
what about the names
david cameron nigel farage theresa may
the speaker of the house
of commons john burke you know order you
know no one talks about any of these
people
now and they were so we thought they
were so important just a few years ago
right but if you look at the leading
characters in the conservative party
okay boris johnson was
at that time back um in 2016 a known
character
but all of the other leading characters
particularly the remain
uh figures from the conservative party
have all been moved on
so the conservative party has moved more
to the right has become more
nationalistic
and all of those remain voices that
there were
around david cameron george osborne as
well his finance minister
they've all been shuffled off as a
result of the brexit process
and also if you look at what's happened
i i think it's just even
less time ago just two years ago we
would have been sat here and probably
would have
been thought of theresa may as maybe a
figure of some ridicule right
if we look at theresa may now she
actually looks like
she was actually particularly with
regard to northern ireland
so she was actually taking a rather
sensible approach to brexit in
comparison to what came to pass with
boris johnson
um we have heard many times that if a
second referendum brexit referendum were
to be held
the the brits would vote to stay in the
eu
do you think that there will ever be a
second referendum i think it is going to
be a long road back
um it was an opinion poll on that topic
just came out today that
said 48 percent of brit the british
population think it was now the wrong
decision
and only 40 percent think it was the
correct decision and then those in
between don't know
but what's really important you've got
to ask is would the european union
want this britain back
in at the moment because this is a
british political system at the moment
which is going through quite some
contortions there's quite some
difficulties
so britain's got to put its own
political dysfunction right first
before it could ever possibly dream of
rejoining let me ask you before we run
out of time
you are british you live here in
germany did brexit alter your sense of
identity somewhat um
how i'm perceived here has not changed
other than a few people
just asking me how can the british have
been that crazy to have gone through
with it that way
but i've maintained all along it's still
very much true it's better through this
process being a brit based in germany
than it would be a german citizen based
in the uk or any other eu citizen based
in the uk
for that matter so yeah i know that my
own personal
and professional and political future
will be here now whereas before the
referendum maybe returning to britain
one day would have been would have been
a possibility
now that's out of the question and
brexit uh was a contributing factor to
that
well john we're glad we've got you on
this side of the the channel anyway john
thank you it's always good talking with
you good to see you here again
five years on concern is growing for at
least 150 000 europeans living in the uk
and tens of thousands of britons
residing
in the european union who are on the
verge of being classified
as undocumented migrants they stand to
lose their citizens rights
including the right to work study and
rent property while some could even face
deportation
that's because many have not applied for
post-brexit residency in the countries
where they are living
and the deadlines to do so in many
countries well that deadline
is next week but today in the uk house
of commons prime minister boris johnson
chose not to focus on those existential
risks instead he talked about the
benefits
of brexit it has allowed us to take back
control of the issues that matter to the
people
of the united kingdom it has given us
the freedom to establish
eight free ports across the country
driving you investment
to develop the fastest vaccine rollout
in europe to protect and invest
in jobs mr speaker over 5.6 million
eu citizens have already applied to our
eu settlement scheme and i would
encourage
anyone who may still be eligible to
apply ahead of the deadline
the clock is ticking again for more on
this i'm joined now by my colleague here
alex forrest whiting alex we have
we've sat here many times talking about
brexit and the fall that we're doing
that again i thought citizens rights
were supposed to be sorted out between
the uk and the eu following brexit but
that's not the case
well broadly they were sorted out but we
have to remember that
countries can impose different residency
rules and that's what's
happened here with countries such as the
uk
and france have very tough rules in
place
now it was agreed that europeans living
in the uk
and britain's living in countries across
the eu would have the right to remain
post-brexit as long as they registered
in time
and as you've just said for some of
those countries the deadline
is next week so let's just take the uk
there are
millions of europeans living there
several million
many of them have um applied for
residency for so-called
settled status but there are still 400
000 cases that haven't yet been sorted
and on top of that campaign is a warning
that another
150 000 people who haven't
even applied for whatever reason which
means that they could well lose
all their rights and that is really
worrying those campaigners
they won't be able to rent they won't be
able to access health care
they won't be able to open bank accounts
or start a new job
they are even at risk of deportation we
have an absolute catastrophe
in the making well i mean that does not
sound good
and what about the brits living across
the eu
you for example yeah me for example
where it does depend where you live
and one of the countries that does have
very tough rules just like the uk
is france in france there are around
about 150
000 brits living there now many of them
will be very
integrated they may have lived there for
decades have french families
have jobs have absolutely no idea that
they
too have to register or else they could
lose
all their rights and that is again
worrying many many people because those
people haven't been contacted
and one group which is called british in
europe
um is saying that those governments
across the eu should have done much more
to warn people
what they are about to lose if they do
not register
you have to go out and find these people
they're vulnerable
who have absolutely no idea what's about
to happen to them and you have to do
what you can there's a moral obligation
on the member states and not just the uk
to make sure that people know what their
rights are and that they're going to
lose those rights unless they take
an action and a step and what that step
is
this is terrifying alex what happens
next well
campaigners have been pleading for
months for governments to be more
lenient
and the netherlands has already agreed
to make sure that they keep their
residency scheme open until the end of
the year
partly because of covid 19. the british
government has just said
that they will start issuing 28-day
notices
to people to warn them that they've got
to apply so they means people have got a
few more weeks but that's not much
and then other countries such as france
well we haven't heard any anything more
so it does mean that there are tens of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of people
who could suddenly find that their lives
have been turned upside down
but you're in good shape we're not going
to lose you hopefully i'm in good shape
our fingers are crossed alex forest
whining as always alex thank you
you